Speaker 1: I've been ignoring this new blog
of Donald Trump's for many weeks because he's
posting daily trash to it of no meaning, significance
and often even related to topics that are
not remotely newsworthy.
It's basically the last gasps for attention
from a guy who is really desperate for attention
but banned for many social media platforms.
But yesterday I came to you and I said, sers
in my audience, the civil investigation into
the Trump Organization being undertaken by
the AG of New York, Letitia James has now
become a criminal investigation.
That was the news yesterday, a major change.
There are now multiple criminal investigations
going on into Donald Trump's organization,
one being done by Manhattan D.A. CI Vance
Jr., the other by New York, Leticia James.
And my instinct yesterday was Trump's going
to go nuts.
Trump's going to go absolutely unhinged as
a result of this.
So I went over to Donald Trump dotcom desk,
which is his blog, and Trump put out almost
like a full page of breathless run on sentences
attacking everyone.
Half the post is in scare quotes and you have
to see it to believe it.
I'm going to try to read some of it, but I
can't do all of it because I'm going to run
out of breath.
OK, so here is some of what Trump wrote in
reaction to now being under to two criminal
probes.
Here we go.
Buckle up.
I have just learned through leaks in the mainstream
media that after being under investigation
from the time I came down the escalator five
and a half years ago, including the fake Russia,
Russia, Russia hoax, the two year, 48 million
dollar, no collusion.
Mueller witch hunt, impeachment hoax, No.
One, impeachment hoax number two.
Another is that the Democrat New York attorney
general has informed my organization that
their investigation is no longer just a civil
matter, but also potentially a criminal investigation
working with the Manhattan district attorney's
office.
That's one sentence, my friends.
OK? Trump goes on to say there is nothing
more corrupt than an investigation that is
in desperate search of a crime.
But make no mistake, that is exactly what
is happening here.
The attorney general of New York literally
campaigned on prosecuting Donald Trump even
before she knew anything about me.
She said that if elected, she would use her
office to look into every aspect of my real
estate dealings.
She swore that she would definitely sue me.
She boasted on video that she would be, and
I quote, a real pain in the ass.
She declared, just wait until I'm in the attorney
general's office and I've got my eyes on Trump
Tower.
She also promised that if elected, she would
join with law enforcement and other attorney
generals.
Do that.
That's it should be attorneys general across
this nation and removing this president from
office.
And it's important that everyone understand
that the days of Donald Trump are coming to
an end.
The attorney general made each of these statements,
not after having had an opportunity to actually
look at the facts, but before she was even
elected, before she had even seen a shred
of evidence.
This is something that happens in failed third
world countries, but not the United States.
If you can run for a prosecutor's office pledging
to take out your enemies and be elected to
that job by partizan voters who wish to enact
political retribution, then we are no longer
a free constitutional democracy.
Likewise, the district attorney's office has
been going after me for years based on a long
discredited lowlife who was not listened to
or given credibility by other prosecutorial
offices and sentenced to three years in prison
for lying and other events unrelated to me.
These investigations have also been going
on for years, with members and associates
of the Trump Organization being viciously
attacked, harassed and threatened in order
to say anything bad about the 44th president
of the United States.
This would include having to make up false
stories.
Numerous documents all prepared by large and
prestigious prestigious law and accounting
firms have been examined and many hours of
testimony have been taken from many people,
some of whom I have not seen in years.
All right.
There's there's like pages and pages and pages.
And it ends with if these prosecutors focused
on real issues, crime would be obliterated
and New York would be great and free again,
extraordinarily triggered.
I mean, just completely and totally off the
rails.
And just imagine what will happen if Donald
Trump or more likely associates or whatever
were to be charged.
It would be completely off the rails.
And I don't know how scared Trump personally
is, but there are a lot of people around Donald
Trump that are very, very scared right now
because of now two criminal investigations
into the Trump organization.
And so I don't know how much more we're going
to continue hearing from Donald Trump.
We spoke already about how Rudy Giuliani has
the walls closing in around him as well.
And Trump seems to have made the decision
that he wants to head for the hills and have
nothing to do with defending Rudy or speaking
out or helping Rudy raise money or any of
it, which he has been asked to do repeatedly.
So it's certainly possible that the fear is
actually starting to reach Donald Trump at
this point in time.
At the same time, the counterbalance to that
is that people we've said this before, people
as narcissistic as Donald Trump tend to think
nobody can touch me.
And that is something which may keep Trump
in a sort of fantasy world where he's not
worried at all now for his sake, it's probably
not going to ever lead to charges against
Donald Trump, as I've said before, and it's
certainly not going to lead to prison time.
So maybe Trump isn't crazy not to be afraid
if he's not afraid, but triggered.
He is.
And I would only expect as these investigations
build and if Rudy Giuliani is charged, this
guy is going to absolutely explode the likes
of which we have probably not yet seen.
We'll have more on this, including Donald
Trump's multipage single paragraph rant.
It's one paragraph, but it's many pages on
his blog on The David Pakman Show Instagram,
which you can find at The David Pakman Show,
on Instagram, at David Pakman show on Instagram.
You can also find me on Instagram.
Not as good as The David Pakman Show account.
I try, but I'm not nearly as good at posting
David Pakman you can find me on Instagram.
We are going to speak to Bill Share after
this brief break and then I will do my mask
rant a little bit later
on
in the show.